die slogans login es ist klar dass sie
es wirklich kleiner live hier von meiner
seite war sonja strohhalme verboten
werden und ich empfehle glas strohhalme
die sind nämlich genau so gut wie
normale strohhalme meinen amazon
affiliate link findet ihr natürlich
unten infobox greenwich habe ich es
wieder einmal waren und willkommen zu
einer neuen folge wie schmeckt ich weiß
ihr habt euch das alles so lange wieder
gewünscht und heute sogar ohne
werbevideo oh mein gott ist denn schon
weihnachten nein sommer und 37 grad und
deswegen bin ich wahrscheinlich gerade
so ein bisschen hibbelig obwohl ich hab
jetzt aufgehört zu schwitzen
das ist schon mal ein ganz großer
vorteil bei der ganzen geschichte hier
lustig ist's noch letzten star und
dachte mir möchte ich jetzt vielleicht
seriöser werden also so wie meine queen
of all time
sallys torten welt oder bleibe ich in
diesem herrlich meine und ich hatte mich
eigentlich dazu entschieden ein bisschen
seriöser zu werden nur über diesen neuen
set also neu alt ich habe mir letztens
nehme ich heute morgen letztens alte wie
schmeckt's videos angeschaut einfach nur
weil ich gucken wollte wie ich das
früher gemacht habe ich das heute mache
das macht man ja zu youtuber sich ein
bisschen reflektiert und da habe ich
gesehen dass ich das alte set irgendwie
vermisse also kein tisch vor mir zu
haben sondern alles in die kamera zu
halten und ich dachte warum probiert das
nicht mal wieder aus ich merke nämlich
wenn ich direkt vor der kamera steht
dass ich ein bisschen lockerer
selbstbewusster hübscher bin wer weiß
und für alle die jetzt abschalten wollen
weil sie sich dachten hätte ich möchte
wissen wie mister bean pizza schmeckt
und keine 24-jährige mit blauen haaren
in einem camp süd barfuß sehen die
bleiben jetzt weiter dran denn es geht
jetzt los
mit dem video nein das ist jimmy smith
vom eigenen
das schnitzen was wir meinen das ist
mein beruf
es tut mir leid für dieses intro es ist
die hitze ich habe den ganzen morgen
schon dieses video nach hinten geschoben
weil man die ganze zeit so schwitzt für
sich keine gedanken finde aussah ich
schwitze und ihr so legen wir ein tool
war miss berlin pizza freude
ich glaube es ist die zwölfte folge weil
ich in dem youtube-video 12 im titel
steht und wir vertrauen jetzt einfach
mal mister bean number one fan in hd von
episode ich habe mich vorher einfach
noch für genk habt ihr mister bean auch
so viel geschafft ich weiß dass ich das
ständig auf superrtl geschaut ab weil es
auch ständig kam und ich weiß dass ich
das immer lustig fand aber jetzt also
wenn ich so drüber nachdenkt hat mich
nicht so entertainers ich sage ja ich
musste mir unbedingt anschauen aber ich
habe so viele freunde gesehen und auch
daran liegen dass meine eltern mich
einfach immer fernsehen schauen
fließend und ich würde mal sagen danke
an dieser stelle mama und papa bei ohne
euch wäre ich nicht so viel geschaut und
würde jetzt dieses format wahrscheinlich
nicht machen
kommen jetzt aber zu der freunde
beziehungsweise zuletzt szene muss ich
mister bean die pizza bestellt mister
bean bestellt eine pizza und als sie
ankam bekommt er einen kleinen schock
denn sie ist superklein und mit einem
biss ist sie im mund schaftlich rund mit
einem bis es ihm und ich habe zu viel
fernsehen geschaut als kind was ist das
denn
saftig rund mit einem biss sind simon
terodde
wenn ihr wisst was in mir gerade durch
den kopf geht dann schreibt man bitte in
die kommentare danke man pop an ihrer
stelle das mir ständig irgendwelche
sachen durch den kopf gehen wo ich keine
ahnung gehabt was das ist aber weiter
geht's mister bean bestellt die pizza
sie ist viel zu klein er hat sie in
einem haps weggegessen und dann
beschließt er zusammen mit seinem freund
eddie eine eigene pizza zu machen warum
ich jetzt so besonders gerne diese pizza
nach machen will ist weil sie so süß
aussieht die sieht aus wie ein teddybär
und ich habe noch nie so eine gesichts
pizza gemacht auch voll die gute
beleidigung ist so eine gesichts spitze
oder das ist ein kompliment zu gesicht
spitze hat die eigentlich schon mal
jemand gesagt dass dein gesicht aussieht
wie eine pizza sotschi
und was die zeichner gemacht haben und
wahrscheinlich nicht bedacht haben ist
dass mister bean butter in seinen
pizzateig rein macht solange ich liebe
habe ich olivenöl in meinen pizzateig
gemacht denn so macht man originale
peter mit butter habe ich noch nie
probiert ich weiß nicht hat das schon
mal macht man das mit butter in
irgendwelchen anderen ländern nutzt
zurück zur story er macht denn die pizza
sie schmeckt super lecker und dann denkt
er sich ja mach ich doch einfach mal ein
pizzaservice auf und verkaufte er ganz
tolle die pizzas und deswegen machen wir
die vegetarische version dieser pizza
weil ich habe jetzt auch keine lust
immer vegetarischen salami zu nehmen und
auf dieser speisekarte beziehungsweise
auf der liefer karte gibt es so eine
kleine brokkoli pizza auch mit den
anderen zutaten nur das in der mitte
statt salami broccoli drin ist und das
möchte ich doch mal ausprobieren und
jetzt geht's los mit ihm will die haben
so kommen wir zu den zutaten
das ist jimmy smith ich bin jetzt mal
rücken können wir zu den zutaten
diesen muss gibt es auch schon kommen
wieder zurück zu tag wir brauchen hilfe
und butter mehl zucker salz und wasser
der shake well
tut das was als kind wir fangen jetzt
einfach an mit diesem kuriosen pizza
butter teig und machen dann später
weiter mit dem belag einwirken trocken
hier bekommt jetzt 75 milliliter wasser
sollte lauwarm sein
auch ein bisschen mithilft der hilfe 250
gramm mehl packen wir eine schüssel
das meer wird gesalzen und ganz
professionell ihrem finger umrühren
ich bin so blöd ich mache mir das safe
schmutzig das schätze ich hat mit
kochschürze und das hier war es heute
ist der tag an dem ich angst hier
ich habe auch noch meine tiny
kochschürze aber es ist meine teile
kochschürze führt eine kitchen
heute ist bp manager können muss endlich
mal meinen eigenen stürzen merge
rausbringen ach so sagt eigentlich um
einen blauen haaren gefällt euch ich mal
es muss einem liebevoll aber auch
vielleicht gefällt euch ja auch wir
nehmen jetzt mal die hälfte unserer
mutter und geben sie in unsere schüssel
und jetzt kommt auch noch unsere liebe
mit unseren gewaschenen händen werden
wir jetzt das verkündeten macht spaß
hier
[Musik]
wer hätte es gedacht wurde etwas
harmonie es gibt mit pizza und wie immer
bei hilfe muss das ding sich jetzt
erstmal ausruhen
gute nacht dass mario spielen
kleinkindern gute nacht kommen geht zum
belag dieser delicious pizza und da
sehen wir auf dem tisch stehen grüne
paprika rote paprika pilze zwiebeln
tomatenketchup ich habe jetzt keine
frischen tomaten besorgt sondern tomaten
aus der dose weil ich jetzt nicht das
noch extra schälen
und wir müssen es anscheinend match
möchte ich weiß nicht was dieser
salatkopf der macht aber wir machen
keinen salat auf unsere pizza wir fangen
an indem wir eine dose tomaten in einen
topf und nach mister wiens geheimrezept
kommt es auch noch ketchup bereit sagt
einer stop stop und das müssen wir jetzt
zum kochen bringen
ich werde das mal auf mich wir nutzen
die zeit um unser gemüse zu schneiden
und fragen uns dabei warum es immer noch
menschen gibt die grüne paprika essen
wir brauchen von den champignons perfekt
bescheiden ich hätte nicht gedacht dass
es klappt das ist jetzt für alle leute
die sich immer aufregen dass sie direkt
voll kamera arbeit es ist so kompliziert
mit nur einer hand ich muss die zwiebel
schneiden aber mir fällt kein zögern um
sie zu schneiden
[Musik]
ihr könnt jetzt natürlich cool sein und
die zwiebeln anbraten und sowas aber wir
schmeißen sie so direkt in den topf das
siehst du da bist du hast ja eine show
moderieren
ich habe auch gesehen dass in ganz zart
tomaten drauf gemalt ich habe zum glück
noch kleine tomaten
die müssen auch noch in scheiben
geschnitten ehren kommen wir machen es
noch mal so weit so schön aussieht saada
beträgt mit auch schon langsam alt oder
unsere tomaten pumpe wird gerührt ein
bisschen
frei und sind natürlich ein bisschen
egal ob hey ich habs kind auch nie
hinterfragt warum mister bean so komisch
spricht spricht er auch so in den film
das schmeckt man dem ketchup gar nicht
mal so schlecht was lag da wir die
vegetarische version machen brauchen wir
natürlich auch brokkoli und dann kaufe
ich gerne den gefrorenen bei diesem
vorgeschnitten lange haltbar und sieht
einfach nur ich sag mal so fantastisch
aus oh mein gott mein tag macht
geräusche
das klingt wie kuhn säure mit olivenöl
höre ich definitiv nie beim pizzateig
was den müssen wir jetzt vorbei ist
komisch der teig ich bin so gespannt wie
es sich anfühlen wird im mund zur und
ausschneiden daraus nicht auch ohren
machen
ja ich liebe manchmal meinen job gemacht
aber ich habe es gemacht wird
wo hast du richtig süß ab jetzt beginnt
endlich der spaßige teil und zwar das
bild
dafür nehmen wir uns was von unserer
super heißen und leckeren tomatensoße
verrühren berühren verteilen
und ganz wichtig mister bean legt viel
wert darauf dass ein schöner die garant
zu sehen ist deswegen müsst ihr
aufpassen ist ja nicht zu weit nach
außen die ohren sehen auch immer aus wie
kleine pizzen da auch noch vorsichtig
sein mit dem rand wo der belag wird
jetzt richtig tricky weil manche sachen
unter dem käse liegen und manche sachen
über dem käse das sieht man an der art
wie es gezeichnet ist ja wann das hat
ihren recherchen job wieder
super gemacht die paprika zum beispiel
ist unter dem käse und die rote paprika
ordentlich vergessen
die tomate scheiben sind auch unter dem
käse drei tomaten scheibchen könnte sich
ein paar maß und auch unter dem kiel und
jetzt muss erst mal der käse obendrauf
und so sieht der zwischenstand auch sehr
brokkoli soll in dem fall die namen
seien
und jetzt kommt der moment in dem ich so
richtig stolz bilden wir brauchen zwei
champions für die ohren
damit ist der kurs stimmt das habe ich
nicht mal vorgestellt es kommt nämlich
noch schwarze und diesen als augen dazu
habe ich lange nichts gemacht doch
könnte gerade viel aber ich habe
irgendwie gefühl ist es tut wenig wie
schmeckt videos in letzter zeit gemacht
habe das ist aber auch weil ich auch so
viele andere formate habe zum beispiel
drei komplexe ballern und die will ich
auch regelmäßig machen und dann vergisst
man dass du bist toll aus hier ist sie
ziemlich wunderschön und nun brauchen
wir den
[Musik]
ja und ich träume auf nennen aber ich
muss das nicht interessieren denn jetzt
kommt das ergebnis übergang nicht meiner
was mache ich hallo in vanessas
italienischen restaurant ich hätte gerne
eine teddy pizza broccoli und matthew
keys bitte danke schön und ich muss auch
wenn mit diesem restaurant spielen
[Musik]
ich bin absolut stolz auf mich ich finde
die pizza als wunderschön geworden ich
hoffe sie schmeckt wenigstens ein
bisschen mit dem muttertag
das sieht mir nämlich eher aus als ob
das sowieso ein keks geworden aber nun
stellen uns natürlich wieder der
allerwichtigsten frage wie schmeckt die
pizza aus mister bean aus mister bean
pizza lieferservice irgendwie fehlt mir
noch der italian flair ok google
na dann füge ich jetzt einfach
italienische musik ein
schon besser der tageswertung
[Musik]
stellt euch vor ihr habt einen
weihnachtsplätzchen und da ist seit
pippa belag drauf und dann
weihnachtsplätzchen ist das ist drei mal
so schnell ich würde absolut nicht
empfehlen den teig mit butter statt mit
olivenöl zu machen aber für dieses
experiment muss ich sagen das ist
geglückt und es sieht fantastisch aus
ich hoffe natürlich wie immer euch hat
die folge gefallen und wenn ja dann
zeigt es mir mit einem daumen nach oben
das hilft mir besonders weiter denn
dadurch kommt man zum beispiel in die
trends und wird öfter vorgeschlagen also
als tipp so für die zukunft wenn ihr
jemanden hat wo er sagt den möglich
unterstützen denkt einfach kurz an
diesen dauern schreibt mir gerne weiter
fleißig kommentare was ich denn als
nächstes kochen soll auf die pizza bin
ich auch nur durch dieses kommentar
gekommen hieß es danke schön und wenn
ihr irgendwo was gesehen habe was ich
mal nachkochen soll dann würde mir sehr
helfen wenn ihr nicht nur das gericht
und die serie oder den film sagt sondern
zum beispiel auch am anfang am ende bei
serien zum beispiel in der staffel in
der folge wenn ihr es wisst und soweit
wir wissen worauf ich hinaus möchte denn
manchmal lese ich etwas und habe keine
ahnung wo das vorkommt und ist ganz
schön viel arbeit ist erst mal raus zu
finden wenn ihr nämlich gerade etwas
schaut und wo ihr dann war da sollte man
das aber eingeschränkt nach machen
dann schreibt einfach ganz kurze info
wenn ihr es wisst wenn nicht dann ist
jetzt nicht für mich recherchieren nur
so als zwischen und sonst wünsche ich
euch noch einen schönen sommer genießt
das leben und wir sehen uns dann beim
nächsten mal wieder
[Musik]